there is a stranger who comes to this
village from the sea he comes in the
winter when people are hungry brings
fish comes on the king tide that was
last night
took I believe that an enemy is coming
from far away I'm looking for warriors
this stranger others like him
[Music]
I'm building an alliance to defend us
it's very important that I see this man
[Music]
Barry Allen Bruce Wayne
you said that like it explains why
there's a total stranger sitting in the
dark in my second favorite chair he said
he'll fight with us
more or less
probably more or less he said no he said
no look man I don't know who you are but
whoever you're looking for
[Music]
so you're fast that feels like an
oversimplification I'm putting together
a team people with special abilities see
I believe enemies are coming and stop
right there I'm in you are just like
that yeah I need friends
alright guys heat this
[Applause]
I heard about you didn't think you were
real
I'm realize useful
Arthur curry here you can talk to fish
I know you have abilities I just don't
know what they are my special skills
include viola a web design fluent in
sign language gorilla sign language
silica based quartz and fabric brazen
resistant heat resistant yeah I do
competitive ice dancing what they use on
the space shuttle to prevent it from
burning up on reentry
I do very competitive ice dancing
whoever you're looking for
[Music]
[Music]
he's a Batman
so you're fast that feels like an
oversimplification I'm putting together
a team people with special abilities you
see I believe enemies are coming stop
right there
I'm in you are yeah I need friends I
believe there is a stranger comes to
this village from the sea it comes in
the winter when the people are hungry it
brings fish he comes on the King tide I
was last night it won't add fealty those
goodies kilos rutila's icebergs in the
harbor for months since the last ship
got through well this stranger doesn't
come by ship
there are enemies coming from far away I
need warriors I'm building an alliance
and defend ourselves you should get out
can you at least point me to Atlantis
Arthur curry also known as protector of
the oceans the aquaman here you can talk
to fish okay here's the thing I'm afraid
of bugs and guns and obviously Tom
Bergeron iqp here it's really cool you
guys seem ready to do battle and stuff
but full transparency I've never done
battle I've just pushed some people and
run away save one save one person Oh
which one don't talk don't fight get in
get one out and then you'll know
okay
[Music]
how many of you are there not enough
eight people abducted from our near STAR
Labs here's the potential perp
parademons okay
the demons must have caught the scent of
the mother box they carried people away
to find out what they know so the rest
of your life nine oh the head of STAR
Labs was taken as well you made it so
then there must be a nest nearby I
plotted all the sightings of Metropolis
Gotham no pattern I can see the lines on
the map don't converge on land Beasley
back to Braxton Island between the two
cities Gotham Harbor
these are air vents they all lead down
to the tunnel to Metropolis project it
was abandoned in his 29 do you really
think that oh wow they just they really
just vanished
uh-oh that's rude
[Music]
[Music]
thanks offering but I'll take it from
here
do I know you
[Music]
primitive feelings what are we under
Rana
Gotham Harbor
you've got a team here Superman you
bring this team together better than I
ever could his strength doesn't matter
how strong you are or what abilities you
might have more human than I am he lived
in this world fell in love and a job
despite all that power world needs
Superman on the team needs Clark this is
man's best hope down with the modern
world back to the dark ages and the
safety of holy fear
[Applause]
I don't play what are you a believer
yeah
we have to be ready
you me the others
does the tech coming from far away
not coming loose it's already here the
others where are they Arthur curry the
Aquaman
so nem organic and biomechatronics body
parts the cyborgs you should probably
move Barry Allen
whoever you're looking for it's not me
he's a Batman
they said the age of heroes who never
come again past him
[Applause]
what are your superpowers again I'm rich
watch our
[Music]
shall we
it's good to see you playing well with
others again just like a bat I dig it
may be temporary
what did you do this weekend me nothing
very interesting the world remains in
mourning after the death of the Superman
he said the age of heroes who never come
again past him we don't have any more
time something is coming
I protected you
[Music]
no lectures
[Music]
no Kryptonian
[Music]
which maybe say
like all the others one this is the days
where mums biggest concerns were
exploding windup penguins this is crazy
honestly I think we're all gonna die
each of us in some way is held back
don't engage alone until this together
really cool you guys seem ready to do
battle and stuff I've never done battle
just push some people run away
relax Alfred I'll take it from here do I
know you
Superman was a beacon to the world
he didn't just save people
to see the best parts of ourselves
I don't recognize this way
we all have to recognize
we should save it
[Music]
how many of you are there not enough do
you really think this oh wow they just
they really just vanish huh oh that's
rude
[Music]
you said you've come
now that's hope you're not too late
[Music]
I'll take that as a yes what the ring
[Music]
violence acts of war and terrorism are
all on the rise I had a dream it was the
end of the world
I think it's something more something
darker we're asking people we'd unknown
to risk their lives strong man and
strong as alone never heard that it's my
saying that's the opposite of what the
saying is
divided we are not enough
worldly
[Music]
I made him a promise
why I brought you together
ride ain't over yet man
[Music]
Oh awesome as the bat-signal that's your
sorry
it's your signal that means we have to
go now yeah it's so cool what's on your
weird mind I'm putting together a team
I mean you are beautiful
these things are gonna keep coming you
get technical I'm on bug duty
let's do it
ride ain't over yet my man
Justice League rated pg-13 long before I
was born he came as the spearhead of an
alien invasion which made me feel
we have families what does everyone keep
down
there are enemies coming from far away I
knew warriors
just like a bat you really are out of
your mind I'm not the one who brought
pitchfork
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't recognize this way
[Music]
we just have to save it
ride ain't over yet my man
[Music]